so you and i uh
have been working together for
five years on this
when did you come to our accelerator is
it 2015 or 16. 2016. so we met when you
were when you had your angel summit
down by uh down by the water there in
san francisco
and then we were part of the accelerator
through that spring uh and then we
sprung into
uh our first wave in the summer so in
july we kind of came out and uh
and then you know started started
hardcore
r d at that point but that was that was
kind of the kickoff
uh
and the concept originally was hey you
had worked at amazon
um i think we're not breaking any ndas
here but
they had aspirations to build stores and
you were involved in that product
early on correct
yeah i mean basically in in the process
of working on go and books
uh it just became i mean the challenge
was how do you build you know how do you
build 80 000 stores right and so
in you know short the answer was buy
whole foods but
leading up to that there was a lot of
work on the business model and looking
at like how do you build a repeatable
process um and so in building out books
i mean we built out amazon books in like
six months it was a crazy hair on fire
process and all of the major risk was
around standard construction and and
permitting um and we just we did you
know
a thousand times the innovation on the
internal side but then going through the
standard sort of real estate process
that's where all the red lights were
and so in looking at that there was a
lot of
you could kind of see the writing on the
wall in terms of the need for the
industry to embrace productization and
standardization
but that's really kind of step one and
then obviously as you were alluding to
in the intro
all the eggs break from there to getting
to actually having something that's
viable as a development process
and i think one of the great insights
was hey if you're building on site
that's the equivalent of tesla shipping
a bunch of parts dropping them in your
driveway and building a car in your
driveway
that is the state of building housing
today
and you said there's got to be a better
way let's build the homes
the blocks as we say in a factory ship
them to the location and then do the
last 5 10 15
of the construction process on site um
how has that actually manifested itself
in the real world i know that
phoenix rising a blockable project for
affordable housing
uh had the ribbon cutting i think last
year
yeah it was in it was it was late last
year when we opened it and finally
opened the doors yeah i mean you're
basically trying to move as much of the
process as you can into the factory but
then you know you kind of get to
the larger issue which is uh the
business model which drives ultimately
drives the product development process
so the way that the industry because
modular
modular construction as a process has
been around for decades right and so
it's been around 30 40 years but what
it's typically meant has been to move
the framing process of construction into
the factory
so you
take labor and you move it into a
factory you take supply chain you move
it into a factory and then you're either
building out of wood or you're building
out of steel but ultimately what you're
doing is the building framing
so developers who are the ones who kind
of control what gets built where it gets
built how it gets financed who lives in
it how the value is created they're
ultimately
the ones who drive the economics
previous and a lot of current
incarnations of modular or prefab are
set up to sell to the developer right so
you build some kind of process that's
going to save the developer some amount
of money so let's say
let's say framing is 20 percent of a
construction budget and let's say a
construction budget is 65 percent of the
total development budget so a developer
can look at building their building out
and getting the framing process done in
a factory and if that can save them some
money in some time they'll buy that but
it means you will never really get to
any significant amount of
standardization in the factory because
all you're really doing is the framing
and the developer could always do the
framing on site
so the the modular uh part of the
process is just a commodity and so the
developers basically you know calling
all the factories and saying who can who
can build me
this part of my project cheaper because
that's what'll make my project pencil so
the approach that we took
is very different which as the developer
building a fully standardized
productized system that we manufacture
ourselves but also that we sort of take
the maximum upside of because we're the
developers
so the big the big moment for us was you
know after we got through our first
phases of
you know
product innovation so the framing
prototyping building out a few small
buildings the building that we brought
to um
down to the innovation center that one
time we trucked a building all the way
down loaded it into the innovation
center and people are like walking into
a small studio apartment inside of a
conference center basically yeah
that was still in the process of
you know what materials are we using how
much labor does it take to build one of
these things what kind of energy
efficiency can we get how do you load it
onto a truck how far can the truck go
what kind of you know what are the
economics of logistics there's so much
that you're working out that's just
baseline
but then the real
the real issue for us was um
becoming the developer and so once you
have those core product uh sort of you
know structural how does it get approved
by the state how does it get approved by
the local municipality once you've
worked through all that
then you have the set of problems which
is about well how do i how do i develop
using this system
and so nelson and i
um in going through that process that's
really where the value is created and
all of your decisions change because if
you look at the economics of
a real estate development versus the
economics of selling a modular product
to a developer they don't even resemble
each other and that was kind of the big
that was the big insight so to recap
there if you sell a
uh developer a unit
they are going to do um what's in their
best interest which is get the lowest
possible price chi charge the highest
possible price when they complete the
project and between those two numbers is
their profit
so that is uh for them
i guess the virtuous way to run their
business but what you realized was they
they probably maybe don't care about the
long-term value of the
asset
in the way their customer who is
actually building the units and owning
them does correct
well if there's an incentive issue there
it is but it's also like real estate is
just this unique business model right so
like in a typical
product sale like you you can make a
product someone can buy the product you
make some margin on the product and they
purchase the product and use the project
the developer is a bit of an
intermediary the developer is eventually
going to rent right so they're going to
rent these units
into the marketplace so for a developer
where the disconnect happens is
for every dollar that the modular
construction company can make as a
profit that dollar is worth ten dollars
in equity to the developer
right so the modular uh contractor
uh it's never worth as much to them as
it is to the developer to get a cheaper
price and so you all you have this this
constant fight over you know what should
the cost be like we'll get we get
multiple inquiries every week from
developers who would love to buy our
product to use for their project and the
only question that they'll ask is what's
your cost
and the reason that they're asking that
question is because they can't get
projects to pencil right so they're
looking at their their build they've got
some dirt they've got it lined up they
know what the rents are they want to go
build something but it's too expensive
it's too expensive in the market so they
look at modular plants and saying you
should make this cheaper for me if you
make it cheaper for me i don't really
care what happens to you but if you make
this cheaper for me now all the
economics work and i've got something
that's worth hundreds of millions of
dollars because you've built it for me
at a cost that now allows me to take the
equity in the project
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products all together let me
guess way too much time well odoo is
here to help you with that odoo is a
suite of business apps that runs your
entire company on one platform a
streamline workflows by bringing all
your information together plus odoo's
integrations eliminate repetitive tasks
and data entry if you only need two or
three apps to optimize your workflow
well that's all you're going to pay for
odoo won't stick you with the bill for
apps you don't use
and odoo has an app for every business
need they offer 30 main apps that are
updated regularly and over 16 000 apps
from their active open source community
so you can keep your books tight with
their financial software and you can add
their sales and crm apps to help provide
a clear and organized view of your
business
it's a great platform many people are
using in the startup community and
raving about it your first app is free
forever and right now odoo is sweetening
the pot with a thousand dollar credit on
your first implementation pack that's
right no joke one thousand off go get
that one thousand dollar credit at
odoo.com twist that's odo.com
twist odo.com